evolution of natural selection
does not tell us the deeper question
that we're asking the answer to the
deeper question which is why what what
why
what what's this deeper reality and
what's it up to and why it all it tells
us is that whatever reality is
it's not what you see
what you see
is is just
an adaptive fiction
so just to linger on this fascinating
bold question
that shakes you out of
your dream state
does this fiction still help you in
building intuitions as literary fiction
does
about reality
the reason we read literary fiction
uh is it helps us
build intuitions and understanding in
indirect ways sneak up to the difficult
questions of human nature great fiction
same with this observed reality
um
does this interface that we get this
fictional interface help us build
intuition about deeper truths
of how this whole mess works
well
i think that
each theory that we propose will give
its own answer to that question right so
when the physicists are proposing
these structures like the amplitude and
cosmological polytope associated and so
forth beyond space time we can then ask
your question for those specific
structures and say how much information
for example
does evolution financial selection and
the the
kinds of sensory
uh
systems that we have right now give us
about this deeper
reality and and
why did we evolve this way we can try to
answer that that question from within
the deeper so there's not going to be a
general answer i think we're going to
what we'll have to do is posit these new
deeper theories and then try to answer
your question
within the framework of those deeper
theories knowing full well that there
will be an even deeper theory
so is it is this paralyzing though
because uh how do we know we're not
completely adrift
uh out to sea lost forever from
so like that our theories are completely
lost so if if it's
all uh
if we can never truly deeply introspect
to the bottom
if it's always just turtles on top of
turtles infinitely
um isn't that paralyzing for the
scientific mind
well
it's interesting that you say introspect
to the bottom
because there there is that there is one
i mean again this isn't the same spirit
of what i said before which is it
depends on what answer you give to
what's beyond space time what answer we
would give to your question right so but
one answer that um is interesting to
explore is something that spiritual
traditions have said for thousands of
years but haven't said precisely so
we can't take it seriously in science
until it's made precise but we might be
able to make it precise
and and that is that um
they've they've also said something like
um space and time aren't fundamental
they're maya they're their illusion
and but but that um
if you look inside if you introspect
uh and let go of all of your particular
perceptions
uh you will come to something that's
beyond conceptual thought
and that
is
what they claim uh being in contact with
the deep ground of being that that
transcends any particular conceptual
understanding
if that is correct now i'm not saying is
correct
but and i'm not saying it's not correct
i'm just saying if that's correct
then it would be the case that as
scientists because
we also are in touch with this ground of
being
we would then
not be able to conceptually understand
ourselves all the way
but we could know ourselves just by
being ourselves
and so we would there would be a sense
in which
there is a fundamental grounding to the
whole enterprise because we're not
separate from the enterprise
this is the opposite of third the the
impersonal third-person science this
this would make science equally personal
personal all the way down
and and but but nevertheless scientific
because the scientific method would
still be
what we would use all the way
down for the conceptual understanding
unfortunately you still don't know if
you went all the way down it's possible
that this kind of whatever consciousness
is and we'll talk about it is getting um
the cliche statement of be yourself uh
is is it it is somehow digging at a
deeper truth of reality but you still
don't know when you get to the bottom
you know a lot of people they'll take
psychedelic drugs and they'll say well
that takes my mind to certain places
where it feels like that is
revealing some deeper truth of reality
but you still
it could be interfaces on top of
interfaces that's that's
in your view of this
you really don't know that means gators
and completeness is that you really
don't know my own view on it
for what it's worth
because i don't know the right answer
but my own view on it right now is that
it um
it's never ending
i think that there will never that this
is great as i said before great um job
security for science
and that we
if this is true and if if consciousness
is somehow important or fundamental in
the universe this may be an important
fundamental fact about consciousness
itself that that it's a never-ending
exploration that's going on in some
sense
well
well that's interesting you push back on
the job security okay
so maybe as we understand this kind of
idea deeper and deeper
we understand that the pursuit is not a
fruitful one
then maybe we need to
maybe that's why we don't see
aliens everywhere as you get smarter and
smarter and smarter
you realize that like exploration
is uh there's other fun ways to spend
your time than exploring
you could be um you could be sort of
living maximally in some way that's not
exploration
um you know i could there's all kinds of
video games you can construct and put
yourself inside of them that don't
involve you going outside of the game
world it's uh you know feeling
for my human perspective what seems to
be fun is challenging yourself and
overcoming those challenges so you can
constantly artificially generate
challenges for yourself like sisyphus
and his boulder just and and that's it
so the scientific method that's always
reaching out to the stars that's always
trying to figure out the puzzle on
bottom puzzle the the trick always
trying to get to the bottom turtle
uh maybe if we can
build more and more the intuition that
that's uh infinite pursuit
we get
um
we agreed to start deviating from that
pursuit start enjoying the here and now
versus the
looking out into the unknown always
maybe that's a looking out into the
unknown as a
early
uh
activity
for a species
that's evolved i'm just sort of saying
uh pushing back as you've probably got a
lot of scientists excited in terms of
job security i could i could envision
where it's not job security where
scientists become more and more useless
maybe they're like the holders of the
ancient wisdom
uh that's that allows us to study our
own history but
not much more than that just to get well
let's push back that's good push back
i'll i'll put one in there for the
scientists again yes but but sure but
then i'll take the other side too so
when
faraday did all of his experiments with
magnets and electricity and so forth he
came with all this wonderful empirical
data and
james clerk maxwell looked at it and
wrote down a few equations which we can
now write down in the single equation
the maxwell equation if we use geometric
algebra just one equation
that opened up
unbelievable technologies you know
people are zooming
and talking to each other around the
world
um
the whole electronics industry
there was something
that transformed our lives in a very
positive way
with the theories beyond space time
here's one potential
right now most of the galaxies that we
see
um we can see them but we know that we
could never get to them no matter how
fast we traveled they're going away from
us at
the speed of light or beyond so we can't
we can't ever get to them so there's all
this beautiful real estate that's just
smiling and waving at us and we can
never get to it
yeah but that's if we go through space
time
but if we recognize that space-time is
just a data structure
it's not fundamental
we're not
little things inside space-time
space-time is a little data structure
in our perceptions
it's just the other way around
once we understand that
and when we get equations for the stuff
that's beyond space time
maybe we won't have to go through space
time maybe we can go around it maybe i
can go to proxima centauri and not go
through space i can just
go right there directly it's a data
structure we can start to play with it
so so i think that
my for what it's worth my take would be
that
that the endless
sequence of theories that we could
contemplate building will lead to an
endless
sequence of new
remarkable insights into the
potentialities the possibilities that
would that would that would seem
miraculous to us and that we will be
motivated to continue the exploration
partly um just for the technological
innovations that that come out
but
you're the other thing that you
mentioned though what about just being
what if we when we decide instead of all
this doing and exploring what about
being my guess is that the best
scientists
will do both and that
the
act of being
will be a place where they get many of
their ideas
and that they then pull into the
conceptual realm and i think many of the
best scientists youth like einstein
comes to mind right where these guys say
look i didn't come up with these ideas
by a conceptual analysis i was thinking
in vague images and i was it was just
something
non-conceptual and then it took me a
long long time to pull it out into
concepts and then longer to put it into
math but the real insights didn't come
from just slavishly right you know
playing with equations they came from a
deeper place
and so there there may be this going
back and forth between the complete
non-conceptual
where there's essentially no end to the
wisdom and then conceptual systems where
there's the girdle limits
that we have to that
and that may be if consciousness is
is important and fundamental that may be
what consciousness at least part of what
consciousness is about is this
discovering itself
discovering its possibilities so to
speak we can talk about what that might
mean
um
by
going from the non-conceptual to the
conceptual and back back and forth
you